Hey everybody.
This is Jeff Posnick from the
YouTube Developer Relations
team.
And we're continuing
a series of videos
about the migration
between the older legacy
version of the
YouTube data API v2
onto the newer version
of the data API v3.
We strongly encourage folks to
begin that migration process,
if you haven't done so yet.
And we wanted to highlight
certain types of functionality
and talk about the v2
way of doing things,
and how you would go and do
the same sort of thing in v3.
We're going to start by talking
about how you would actually
get a list of videos that are
in a given channel using v3,
the data API.
Folks familiar with
v2 the data API
know that you do this pretty
much with a single RESTful API
call.
You look for the user upload's
feed for a given channel,
and you get back a list of
videos by default in an XML
format, although you could
also ask for it JSON format
if you want.
In v3, it involves a slightly
different set of operations.
And it's just keeping with
the overall philosophy with v3
in that you return a very
specific set of information
for a specific API
call, rather than
returning a lot of information.
So it's a little bit
more of a focused API.
And the other main difference
is that in v3, we work primarily
with channel IDs rather
than legacy usernames.
So if you're familiar with the
more v2 way of doing things,
where every channel
had a legacy username,
you need to start thinking
about channel IDs instead.
And this is particularly
important because moving
forward, not every channel
does have a legacy username.
So if you did want to uniquely
identify any given channel,
there are going to be
those channels that
don't have the legacy
usernames, and you
do need to get comfortable
working with channel IDs.
So let's actually
walk through the steps
of doing the
operation of getting
the uploads in a channel
using version 3 of the API.
And we're going to
switch now to a screen
share of that I have up.
And what I have open here
is the Google APIs Explorer.
This is a great resource
for playing around
with version 3 of the data API
or using our analytics API,
or any other of the
modern Google APIs.
And it gives you a way
of making API calls
within the context of
this nice browser web form
in trying out
different parameters.
So when you are
actually writing code
for using this sort of thing
in your own applications,
you're probably going to want
to use your client libraries.
But this is a
neutral, agnostic way
of showing off the API calls.
So that being said, there
are two different steps
for getting the uploads
in a given channel,
assuming that you
know-- and we're
going to assume right now that
we know that channel's legacy
username.
The first step is to get
back the playlist ID that
corresponds to the
uploads for that channel.
And the way we do that is by
making a YouTube.channels.list
call.
And we have that open
here in the API Explorer.
And when making
version 3 API calls,
pretty much the convention that
all the list operations follow
is that you have one
parameter called Parts.
And you set this to a
value that is a little bit
dependent upon the given method.
And in this particular
case, the YouTube
channels that list takes
these values over here
in the documentation.
We can describe exactly
what all of them do.
And what we want is the
content details part.
So instead of returning every
single piece of information
that we know about the
channel in every API response,
which could get
very bloated, you
have to explicitly state
what kind of information
you want to get back.
And you get a nice really
compact API response back.
So we're going to say we want
the content details part back,
and this is how we get
the uploads playlist ID.
And there's this parameter
called forUsername.
As the documentation states,
it lets you pass in a legacy
YouTube username, assuming
that the channel that you're
interested in has one.
And it will return information
corresponding to that channel.
So this is like a shortcut
of getting information
about a channel or looking up
a channel's ID, if all you know
is the legacy username.
So in this particular
case, we're
going to look up the
Google Developers channel.
That's a legacy username.
And we're going to
scroll down a bit.
We don't need any of these
other fields right now.
And click Execute, and it's
making the API call for us.
You'll see these
are the parameters.
This is the actual RESTful
URL that's being requested.
And you get back
this JSON response.
And you'll see over
here, because we're only
asking for information
about one specific channel,
the item's return array only has
one element, not surprisingly.
You do you get this
channel ID right here.
If we did want to use
that information later on,
that might be useful.
But in the particular context
of what we're doing here,
we want the uploads playlist ID.
So I'm going to just copy that.
If you were writing real
code, you would obviously
save it to a local variable
and use it in a follow-up call.
And I'm going to now
make another API call--
and just open up a
new tab for that.
And this is going to be a
YouTube playlist items list.
And again, the thing
to keep in mind
is that in version 3
of the API, many things
are considered playlists.
Instead of, in version 2,
where you would go and get
specifically the uploads
feed corresponding to a given
channel, in version
3, you first look up
the playlist that corresponds
to the uploads for the channel.
And then you do the standard
YouTube playlist items
list call.
And this is the same
API call that you
would use if you were
getting information
about a user-generated playlist.
It's really quite equivalent.
So you'll see that a lot
in version 3 of the API,
where we reuse methods
or overload the function
of methods so that
they could be used
for a variety of
different operations.
So in this particular case, we
have this part parameter again.
I'm going to pass in
the value snippet here.
And snippet is a
part that contains
the most relevant information
about any given response
item, things that would
be useful if you were to,
for instance, want to
display information
about the response
like in a web browser.
So it'll contain the
title for each item,
it'll contain a thumbnail,
it'll contain a description.
And that's the
type of information
that we want about all the
uploads in a given channel.
So I am going to take
that copied playlist ID,
and I'm going to paste it
into the playlist ID field.
This is something to
really keep in mind.
You want this in the
playlist ID parameter.
There's a separate
parameter called ID.
And that takes in
something that's
different than the playlist ID.
So please-- this is a
common source of confusion--
make sure that you're
setting the playlist ID
parameter in this
particular case.
And I'm also going to
set max results to 50.
One of the things
you'll notice is
that Mac's results
is, by default, set
to five in version 3 of
the API, which is fine
if you are going to be
displaying the results on a web
page, and you don't
want a really, really,
long list of videos.
But in this particular
case, I want
to get information about as
many as I could in a single API
call.
And the most you
could get back is 50.
I'm going to click
Execute at this point.
And you scroll down, and
you'll see this items array
similar to what we saw
for the previous one.
But in this case, the items
array has multiple items in it,
because there are,
not surprisingly,
quite a few uploads in the
Google Developers channel.
You'll have information about
when that upload was published,
and titles,
descriptions, thumbnails,
things I mentioned before.
One other thing that
I wanted to point out
is the way paging works
in version 3 of the API,
because this is something
that's different than version 2
as well.
So previously in
version 2, you could
pass in whatever you
wanted as the start index.
And that would allow you
to jump to different places
within something like
an upload's feed.
In version 3 of
the API, we don't
take in a start index parameter.
We take in what's known
as a paging token.
And that gets returned
in the API response.
And it's used when you
build up your next request,
as a way of saying,
hey, you know
I've gotten this
page of results.
Give me the next
This allows for certain
efficiencies on the server,
and it means that you get a more
reliable paging experience when
you're using version 3.
It just allows things to be
a little bit more efficient,
and it means that less likely
to be duplicates or things that
are unordered.
So let's actually take in
that next page token value
from this response.
And we're going to construct
the next page of requests
by pasting it in here.
So we're going to have
all the same parameters,
but we're sending
page token now.
And if I click Execute,
things should return back.
But in this particular case, I
get a different set of results.
This is basically
results 51 through 100.
And we can continue doing that.
Basically as long as there's
a next page token returned,
that means that there is
another page of results
that you could get back.
And you could
loop, more or less,
until you stop getting
back next page tokens.
As soon as that
stops being returned,
you know that you've
reached the end of the list.
So hopefully that's
a good overview
for how you would do
something in version 2,
and then how you would
do the v3 equivalent.
Stay tuned for future shows.
They cover more topics
in version 3 of the API.
And thanks so much
for joining us.
Again, I'm Jeff Posnick from
the Developer Relations team.
And stay tuned.
Cheers.